مع افتتاح مونديال قطر الترند عالميا
وعربيا خال الا من اخبار كره القدم
ومغامرات ماسك في تويتر مستمر وهذه المره
اعاد نجمه منصه ترامب
وموظفوه جيل زد يطالبون باجازه لصحتهم
النفسيه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
البدايه من الخبر الاول حول العالم كاس
العالم
حول العالم واللي بيستنوه المليارات كل
اربع سنوات وهذه النسخه بتستضيفها قطر
طبعا انطلاق كاس العالم وكما هو متوقع
ترند اول حول العالم بكل اللغات وعلى
الاغلب طبعا هذا الحال رح يكمل معانا
الشهر كله والمونديال هيكون نجم كل من
الصاد باخباره وصوره ومقاطع والمباريات
والنتائج ونهايه طبعا بتشويش البطل الى
جانب الهاشتاج هذا المتداول عالميا همم في
السعوديه وعربيا هاشتاج محمد بن سلمان في
قطر
وذلك بعده وصول ولي العهد السعودي للدوحه
تلبيه لدعوه الشيخ تميم لحضور حفل
الافتتاح المونديال
[موسيقى]
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
وجبل الوصوله للدوحه كان انها جوله اسيويه
مهمه جدا وابتسامه مع هذه الجوله في مقاطع
متداوله على تويتر لاشخاص عاشوا واندمجوا
في المجتمع السعودي ومن ابرز القصص
والمقاطع المتداوله قصه صدر الدين
الاندونيسي اللي عاش في السعوديه من 20
سنه وفي كمان طالب اندونيسي اسمه محمد
فردوس له مقطع متداول ايضا وفي بيتكلم
عربي فصيحه جدا عن المنحه اللي قدمت له
علشان يكمل دراسته في جامعه الملك سعود
وانا 20 سنه
الطبيعي و20 سنه اجلس معاكم قلبي اهل
الجيزان هذه اربطني هنا ههه والله
باصات
والله الشعب
والله
انا اقول لايش لازم ازور جيزه حتى احنا اي
مكان لازم ازورها جيزان وبعدين الاكلات
حقه والسياحه حقه والله وربي هذا انا اقول
لك ايش انت تعرف الاندلسيه السياحه كيف
مشهور وانه ديزا موجود زيه كله ثقافه
واكلات واا المكان ترى
والله 20 سنه
شكرا يا احلى جيزان
وجيئته من دوله اندونيسيه وانا حاليا طالب
في جامعه الملك سعود بالرياض وانا متخصص
في مجال تعليم اللغه العربيه ايضا حينما
انا الطالب الاندونيسي في هذه المملكه انا
استطيع ان اتعامل مع هؤلاء السعوديين في
هذه المقلب في هذه المملكه بتعامل جيد
وكريم هم ايضا يتعاملون بطريقه ان احبك
في مقاطع متداوله كمان لكوريين عايشين في
السعوديه ومندمجين مع ناسها من سنوات مثل
السلوكيون اللي بتعمل كاستاذه مساعده في
قسم الهندسه المعماريه في جامعه الامير
سلطان وتخيلوا انه في كمان رئيس لرابطه
السكان الكوريين في الرياض وهذا اسمه
تصبكم وعايش في السعوديه من اكثر من 45
سنه
[موسيقى]
في مشكله
الدراما اللي صايره في تويتر واللي بطلها
خلاص تحولت رسميه اللي نشرت اخبار يوميا
فابليكم مشاهدينا نشرت اخبار مصر اليوميه
واللي بطلها اليوم مع المسك الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب جالسين على
تويتر
الى تويتر والجماهير وقالت كلمتها
اللي عملوا رئيس تويتر الجديد
اكثر من 15 مليون صورته والنتيجه كانت
لصالح عوده ترامب بنسبه 52% و 48% عرضه
الموضوع يعني انتم متخيلين ايش يعني 15
مليون جالسين بيشاركوا في استفتاء على
تويتر
وعلى فكره من بين المصوتين سياسيين
ومشاهير طبعا وكان من بين ال 15 مليون
اللي صوتوا لهذه النتيجه رئيس الوزراء
الهنغاري فيكتور ارومان اللي نشر تغريده
شارك فيها الاستفتاء وقال خمن او خمن وكيف
ادليت بالصوتي تخميم الناس كان انه صوت
نعم كونوا له تصريحات سابقه داعمه ومادحه
في ترامب عموما بعد هذه النتائج ماسك اعلن
في تغريده انه ربطها بتغريده الاستفتاء
وقال الجماهير قالت كلمتها خلاص
هنا عاد نيجي للنقطه الاهم اللي تويتر كان
في يوم من الايام منصه المفضله ايش رايه
في اللي بيصير ترامب عبر منصته وتروس سوشي
الحطب بوست للناس في لينك استفتاء ماسك
على تويتر وقال لي متابعوه او لمتابعينه
بايجابيه لكن لا تقلقوا ما هنروح مكان
مختلف
كلام من فهم منه انه يعني مو ناوي يرجع
تويتر بس يعني ما في شيء واضح ورغم هذا
الشيء الحساب على طول حساب دونالد ترامب
في تويتر وفي اقل من 24 ساعه وهتى هذه
اللحظه الحساب مجمع 83 مليون متابع طبعا
احنا مشاهدينا بنقول لكم ثلاثه مليون
متابع ترى هو قبل ساعه يعني قبل ما ندخل
الهواء كانت 72 مليون متابع ف- شايفين
يعني انتم همم معدل الزياده
حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا مشاهدينا لانه العداد
الحسابه
هذا الرقم الى جانب اخبار طبعا عوده ترامب
طبعا اخر في نشره ماسك اليوميه اللي هو
جدل طرد الموظفين وتسريحهم ف- من بعد طرد
دفع اولى بالالات ومن بعدها جاء ايميل
بخير ناسيه تشتغل بجهد او جهزوا نفسكم
انكم تنطردوا بلومبرج بتقول انه ماسك
بيجهز دفعه جديده تنطرد يوم الاثنين وهذه
المره المستهدفين هيكونوا من اقسام
المبيعات والشركات وطبعا ما ننسى انه اصلا
اللي بيعملوا ماسك هذا خل الموظفين كثار
يختاروا وهم انه يمشوا من نفسهم ومن كم
يوم كان في موجه استقاله جماعيه بين
مهندسين في الشركه اخبار طرد الالاف من
موظفين تويتر والاستقالات الجماعيه بين
الموظفين كان سبب في اطلاق هاشتاج تصدر
التريند عربيا اسمه قبل اللي يسكر تويتر
الاعتبار انه يعني الموظفين كل ما لم
بيقول له محب احد يشغل المنصه خلاص
اشياء انه يلحق الواحد يعملها قبل اللي
يسكر
فنان فعليا في الكومنتات على تقفيله تويتر
لكن انا شخصيا كان عندي التعليق مفضل
خليني اشوفك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قلبك قبل ما يجي يوم ويسافر
وحياتي عندك لو كان ليا عنده خاطري انك
راجع قلبك
[موسيقى]
خذني
معك خذ
ني معك
[موسيقى]
وانت
العمر
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد الاجازات انواع يعني سنويه
مرضيه عرضيه امومه امومه يعني كلها انواع
انجازات ماتعرف عليها فاهمينها يعني لكن
في دراسه امريكيه جديده طلعت لنا بنوع
اجازه جديده والمطالبين بنوع الاجابه
الاجازه هذه هم جنريشن زي او الجيل
والمقصود بهذه المصطلحهم ما المواليد ما
بين 97 لغايه 2012
سنوات ل 25 سنه
اللي بكلمكم عنها هنا بالطالب فيها او
بيطالبوا فيها حسب الدراسه الامريكيه اكثر
من 82% من الموظفين اللي من جناريشن همم
زيت هي اجازه للصحه العقليه يعني بطالبه
ان الواحد فيهم لما النفسيه تتعب او يحس
انه متضايق يكون هذا عذر يخليه ياخذ اوف
من الشغل يكلم مدير ويقول له وانا نفسيتي
تعبانه يعني يعني الدراسه بتقول كمان انه
يعني مع الانفتاح اللي صاير في الحديث عن
الصحه النفسيه واختفاء وصفه العار جيل
الجديد هذا اجرا في الكلام عن الصحه
النفسيه والعقليه واهميتها لكن حقيقه
الدراسه هذه اثارت عندي الكثير من السجون
ابرزها انه احنا يعني
بنتكلم عن زي مثل ما قلنا يعني اللي منهم
بيشتغلوا هم ناس يعني اعمارهم نقول ما بين
21 و25 سنه يعني هدول ايش شافوا عشان من
الان يطلبه باجازه الصحه نفسيه ايش خلا
مثلا اللي بعد خمسه اللي عشره سنين شغل
عموما خلينا نناقش يعني عشان ما اكون
ظالماهم يمكن عندهم اسباب خلونا نناقش
الموضوع ضيفنا المفضل فيما يخص الصحه
النفسيه من عمان دكتور ليث العبادي الطبيب
النفسي اهلا فيك معنا دكتور همم ليث يعني
صراحه انه هل طبيعي انه 82% من هذا
الاومجيل همم
اللي هم اللي احنا بنقول انهم بيشتغلوا 21
ل25 سنه يبغوا اجازات لصحتهم النفسيه
دائما بس اكون معكم بشكل عام واحد من كل
اربعه سيحتاج ان يرى طبيب نفسي خلال
الحياه حياته يعني 25% فلا شك
ر
بسبب مشكله نفسيه قد لا تصل الى هذا الرقم
ولكن دائما الاجازه تحسن النفسيه دائما
للراحه تعطيك استرخاء انبساط فهو في خلط
صار ما بين الجزء الرفاه وما بين الحاج
الاساسيه العلاجيه كعجازه مرضيه او اجازه
خاصه نفسيه ممكن يسموها اعجاز للرفاهيه
اجازه استمتاع زي اجازه عاديه يعني ممكن
يطالبه بتوسيع الاجازات الثانويه
من الانفتاح وتقرير وصله العراق طب انت
لما تفصل الاجازه النفسيه عن الاجازات
الاخرى انت كانك عملت نوع من وصله العاب
احنا بنحاول قدر الانسان
صبرنا بس معلش لما يتصل موظف ويقول انه
معلش انا اليوم متضايق نفسيتي تعبانه يعني
بليز راح اخذ اوف صراحه يعني بالنسبه
لبقيت الموظفين الموضوع المنظر ما هيكون
واو ما يكون رهيب ابدا
السلوك فعلا ياثر على الناس على نفسيته
سلبا لاحق
انه ليش تحديدا هذا الجيل يعني انت بتقول
اوكي مرتاحين اكثر والدراسه بتقول انهم
مرتاحين اكثر في التعبير عن همم انه موضوع
الامراض النفسيه او التعب النفسي وما الى
ذلك بس صراحه كمان خليني اقول لك اياها من
الناحيه الثانيه ترى ثلاثه ارباع اللي
موجودين شايفين انهم مدلعين انه هذه لا
هذا دلع
يعني مش دلع نحنا بنطلع على شيء اسمه
المنع عن النفسيه واللي ممكن تكون اقل عند
فئات معينه ما بقدر اجزم منه
ما له علاقه
بالعمر بعدين دكتور ليث الصراحه يعني معلش
يعني سوري يعني
اذا هم بدهم اجازه الصحه نفسيه انا روحت
تقاعد يعني ذلحين مبكر يعني ولا ايش اسوي
انا نفسيتي تعبانه كمان كل يوم بصحه
تعبانه
دب دائما الجيل الاكبر وانا مش من هذا
الجيل فما بدافع عنهم بس دايما في ظلم من
الاجيال على اللي اصغر منهم دايما انه هذا
الجيل وهذا الجيل من الاف السنين الالاف
السنين في احفورات تتكلم انه والله هذا
الجيل مش زي الجيلنا وهذا الجيل الجديد
خربان نائم يعني في نوع من الظلم هو مستمر
هو جزء من من الطباع البشريه
انه لا يوجد ضعف او قله منع نفسيه بس قلت
مانع يعني عدم القدره على الاستجابه على
الضغوط فقد يكون شيء يزيد من تعبيرهم وبعض
المطالبات باجازات نفسيه
طيب
بشكل عام انا انا بنصاحب الازازات بشكل
عام
يا سيدي نشتغل يومين في الاسبوع مو مشكله
يا سيدي ناخد رواتب من غير شغل مش مشكله
بس نحن بنتكلم
طيب
كل ما الها الشركات بتشعر تحت الضغط انها
لازم تنفذ الموظفين هذه الاشياء ولا
بيشتكوا مشاكل وكده برايك كيف التعامل مع
هذه المطالبات
المرضيه بشكل عام ممكن نزيدها يومين
والاجازات الرفاهيه نزيدها يومين وممكن
ينعمل النظام تحفيزيزي زي هيك سلوك
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
التعب هو جزء من الحياه زي ما في تعب جسدي
في تعب نفسي تعب النفسي
المرض الذي يؤدي الى اذا وصلت لمرحله انت
بحاجه ان تاخذ اجازه بسبب التعب النفسي
مره تمام بس اذا تكرر هذا الموضوع واصبح
العمل يتاثر
بسبب وضعك لنفسي هنا انت تحتاج ان ترى
مختص وان تبدا في العلاج وقت ممكن الطبيب
يعطيك تقريره وعلى فكره تقبل للمؤسسات لن
تقارير من الاطباء النفسيه ملاحظه الشخصيه
صار افضل يعني ممكن تشرح انه هذا الشخص
مره في مرحله التعب بدون ما يكون هو في
العار انه انا ما بقدر احكي لصوتك
لازم يدخل فعلا طبيب وفحص ما الى ذلك ولا
كلنا هناخذ ايام اوف ونقول تعبانين نفسيا
فيها
يعني
طبيه ممتاز شكرا لك كان معنا من عمان
دكتور طبيب النفسي شكرا
الفيديو
انتبهتوا كيف يعني الرجل رجوله بتتحرك
والممرضين يعني تجمدوا كده في مكانهم ايش
يسووا يعني المفروض هذه جثه واخذاها على
ثلاجه الموتى يعني شوفوا بالله مره كمان
رده فعلهم المساكين
القصه يعني خلينا نقول اذا عرف السبب يعني
انه بطل العجب واا الرجال اللي المفروض
ميت طلع اصلا مميز كده طلع هو نفسه اللي
مفبرك موضوع موته انا عارفه
صدموا اكثر من يعني من كم الابتكار
والابداع في الموضوع فهذا الرجال على ديون
كثيره ومش قادر يدفعها فقرر هو ومرته قصه
موته واستاجروا سيارت اسعاف وتابوت وجابوا
الرجال وحطوه في نصف ساعه في القريه
وبكيوا ولطموا عليه جلسه وترحموا كل شيء
على امل انه يعني موته خلاص
بطوط
[موسيقى]
هو بصراحه يعني حل مبتكر بس يعني كيف
كانوا مفكرين انه يكملوا الموضوع لانه
ببساطه اللي صار انه بعدها شالت الناس
الجثه للمستشفى عشان الاجراءات وتدفن
وهناك عاد انصدموا عايش وعموم من الديون
هيدفعها يعني هيدفعها وفوق كل هذا الشرطه
فتحت تحقيق واحتمال ينسجن كمان على عمته
وطبعا في احتمال يتعاقب كمان ونسجن يعني
عام همم
ممكن همم
مشاهدينا كمان الله
[موسيقى]